bueno pues se trata de un senegalés 31
años este escritor que se llama mohamed
vulgar azar pues esta es su cuarta
novela le había comenzado a escribir a
los 24 años y pues no fue digamos como
una sorpresa porque la verdad es que
esta novela que por ahora no ha sido
traducida en español pero a partir de
ahora seguramente será traducida en
muchísimos idiomas o pues se había
gustado muchísimo ahorita en este otoño
literario que se da aquí en francia
estaba en la lista de todos los grandes
y prestigiosos premios literarios que se
otorgan sobre esta época justamente
varios la crítica pues ya había aclamado
muchísimo este libro y bueno el estado
en liza junto con otras tres personas
había una escritora francesa christine
hongo y dos otros autores un francés y
también un haitiano y esta entrega que
se realizó esta vez sí como lo hacen
tradicionalmente en el restaurante de
lujo aunque queda muy cerca de la ópera
garnier aquí en parís es el presidente
de este jurado
de 10 personas pues el que anunció que
finalmente es este senegalés el primer
africano de áfrica subshariana que se
lleva este este premio y bueno y recibió
su cheque de diez euros se irán ustedes
que eso no es nada pérez que en realidad
el algún culo que viene es un premio
mucho mayor más allá pues del prestigio
que esto puede dar es que en realidad
las ventas pues van a multiplicarse de
hecho el año pasado fue de lotería quien
ganó este premio por la anomalía y él
vendió más de un millón de ejemplares en
esta ocasión puede ser un también un
efecto pandemia pero lo cierto es que
esto no ocurría desde 1984 en ese
momento fue más guerrillas quien se
llevó el premio goncourt por su novela
en la mano